pegi 18
il y a des morts
c'est la guerre
parfois la seule façon d'honorer la
mémoire d'un soldat mort s'est terminée
la mission
[Musique]
après des années à combattre la guerre
nous avait tout changé
mais le travail n'était pas encore
terminée le dso m a donné la charge
d'une nouvelle équipe triée sur le volet
pour une mission doivent se plaisent
j'ai dirigé des soldats
mais ce groupe était bien plus que ça
les cas c'était un expert en démolition
qui avait des problèmes avec l'autorité
ouais éviter le plus dangereux dans le
ciel et nous et c'est jamais l'oublier
audi n'a été la meilleure tireuse
d'élite en russie d'où ce qu'elle
voulait c'était se venger
richard était mon bras droit il me
soutenaient toujours
nos visions l'endroit où notre ennemi
était le plus vulnérable
berlin brûle depuis ses cendres
s'élèvera notre vision d'une nouvelle
au quatrième rage
reisinger bernard il emmène le reich
sous terre
c'est quoi cette odeur l'odeur de la
mort croyez bien qu'il existe une
procédure pour obtenir des informations
comment
a soudain
vont être face à une telle est le reich
pour de bon la gloire de survirage
si tu aimes logique ce combat c'est
important
au rejet par le feu nous étions les fers
de lance
nous étions là vanguard
les pré commandes numériques donnent un
accès instantané aux raids nocturnes
virtuose et à l'opérateur arthur king
day